how did you cheat again like the second
he learns how to use his phone again oh
he goes baby I'm good enough back to the
dating apps right back to the beginning
this guy sucks
[Music]
early last year in January of the 22
um there was this dude who got in this
terrible car accident right narrowly
survives he's laying unconscious in a
hospital bed
um and then this wonderful just
absolutely wonderful and loyal wife you
know what I mean is uh totally just like
her whole life is turned upside down
they got two kids and all that stuff you
know what I mean she's just trying to
figure [__] out so then what's her life
upside down well her husband just got in
a terrible car accident is he dead no he
narrowly survived and is laying
unconscious in a that's my job to do
that's sideways that's not upside down
yeah that's not that bad yeah it could
be worse huh he's he's really been to
Ohio he's really been upside down
okay so
um she started feeling really really
guilty like this that's sideways she
started feeling really part's a
paramedic and he pulls through and he
goes man you sideways full that's not
that bad you ain't upside down I've seen
worse sucks are you dead
it sucks for her it just sucks it's
sideways sucks okay sideways
um so she started feeling guilty and she
started like you know thinking like wild
stuff she started fearing that he got in
this car accident because you know it's
your fault for being all Shakespeare
about it
if you hit me up
my life's so upside down
sucks the [__]
my life so that qualifies as Shakespeare
okay can I say something now we know why
Anthony [__] hates JK news
we're having such a good time and this
got comedy interruptions did you get
Anthony before it's a it's it's it's not
even 30 seconds
and he's like what the [__] are you
talking you're making me upside down
right now doesn't even give him a chance
you're full for making all Shakespeare
can I what can I say it does make better
content though it doesn't remember
content and I thought I interrupted a
lot I just joined
bartender I was just praising your
literally skills
[Laughter]
okay so uh she sideways sucked her life
away
there you go so she starts fearing that
it was her fault because oh she started
feeling guilty that he was maybe texting
her or responding to her while he was
driving and that caused the car accident
so she decides to check his phone but
she said she never has checked before
and then she discovers and uncovered a
slew of text uh and dating app profiles
and social media DMS proving that he'd
been cheating on her with other women
and she's like you should have died in
that car accident [__] yeah well you
know she's got she has to rationalize in
that moment she talks about this in a
video and she's got two kids with him so
she's like look I'm
you know I'm just oh that's rough
baffles on one percent anyways yeah he
is on one percent unplug his ass
so she spends months she spends months
nursing him back to health what helping
him relearn how to walk this [__] does
talk eat you know what I mean how to
like reuse that late
like this is how a cheater walks you
walk like this
what if this fool has Amnesia when he
comes back he goes who am I she's like a
cheater
this is how a cheater eats
here we got this at the infidelity
so petty right the [__] up part is she
nurses them back to health and it takes
months and she learns she teaches them
how to walk like a cheater
um Talk eat
walk like a chicken and use his phone
again and then the second he's able to
use all these skills again he cheats
again oh how does he cheat again like
the second he learns how to use his
phone again oh he goes baby I'm good
enough back to the dating apps right
back to the game this guy's a scumbag
this guy sucks I got handed a second
chance and he [__] up dead not a
devil's advocate but maybe like a
mid-tier demon Advocate yeah
again her behavior and how she like
simped after his [__] kind of
validates his [__] yeah it allowed
him to do that like you can see the
climate in the relationship like dude
you just let him walk all over you kind
of deal even if he's like the father of
her children though yeah that's tough
there's like another person's life or
two other people's lives in perspective
that you're like she's maybe putting it
it's messed up what he's doing but it's
it's equally messed up that she doesn't
stand up first how difficult is it to
find a cheater how difficult though find
a cheater yeah for for women to catch
one yeah to catch one not not very
difficult to catch because especially if
somebody's
how do you find one
it sounds like a TV show yeah find the
to find the catch that yeah it's like a
TV show To Catch a Predator it's like
that yeah yeah you're like gotcha
[__] and then I think the other
side goes but I could change him
that's the part that's bad but also what
are you teaching your children that it's
okay to stay with the cheater regardless
if it's that's true
oh you teach them You Stand By Your Man
like Hillary Clinton but what about what
you're good at all I'm gonna say next
time to play Colleen's Advocate I mean
uh you know for me the biggest thing is
this motherfucker's on one percent yeah
just like turn away
[Laughter]
diagnosis this [__] is a cheater
and in a wheelchair what kind of dad are
you but she might be like you know what
he's a piece of [__] but he's the father
of my children and I don't want them to
go out without a dad
so she's like they need a [__] male
figure in their life do you think a bad
male figures better than all right
that's true that's that's the question
what's better no Father Figure or a bad
father as a no Father Figure Advocate
you turn out great I think because you
know I did
I did have father that's the difference
but you're not a cheater though who
Musashi that we know of I had actually
on catch a cheater and I'm like
oh [__] ah they got me who is your
future father figure I've had several
different Colonel Sanders
good old Colonel Sanders good old Sunny
Chiva
it's like a fictional character
straight to Leo
who's your father
Uncle Sam of Just Kidding Films
so like you know how like Mike Tyson his
father figure was the the coach dude
right oh yeah and then so like
I think legit you just gravitate toward
like oh this guy's [__] cool and then
you might have wrong ones but you might
have yeah
sometimes yeah you get groomed too yeah
but I think there's been times where
different males in my family would be my
father figure or role model so I think
uncles and stuff I have two
[__] [__] why are you laughing
and you're thinking about the dirty
people no I'm just looking up because
you kept saying groomed and then my
uncles yeah I was groomed by my
him realizing like oh [__] like I think
I was groomed
oh my God but I think I think it's not
as simple as being like Oh no matter
what you still have to have a father
this and that your blood father can also
be so bad that the longer you stay with
this person you're gonna absorb their
shitty behaviors that's true and so if
this person's kind of like
uh so out of bounds that they're not
gonna come back to being a good human
that's just who they are then I would
rather have like a stepfather or someone
that's a better role model that I can
learn from and be like men get mentored
from a cool uncle that would grew me
into becoming a good man you know yeah
you think she's capable of choosing
another
possible Father Figure in their life
considering her yeah she's she's hot
yeah yeah
that's kind of that's kind of what I was
asking of like like she was like can
girls like can women like fight like
they can tell like if someone is
cheating or not or like how like I don't
know I just feel like I'm just saying
her her judgment and her choices to like
like does she have the right judgment
dude the right judgment to bring
somebody else
considering the fact that she allowed
this to happen what she could do though
is look okay
you you have the one percent uh husband
that's cheating you kick him out of here
right and now she's a murderer yeah or
whatever what and then and then but he's
already he's always crazy he's already
on the way out it's sideways and then
you just throw on the YouTube put on
some Andrew Tate and let the owl go [__]
oh Mike uh you know what I mean he's a
he got some good boys in agreement my
story is crazy
he's like he's on one percent
give him some [__] you know uh a
little entertainment
even and out or something maybe some
Shapiro in there what a playlist this
might sound kind of cold but I think the
world the world would look at the
situation and be like oh she worked so
hard poor girl right but then I would
have been like you saw the warning signs
why did you invest your time into
someone who wasn't going to reciprocate
any goodness back to you you saw someone
who repeatedly [__] up already and now
you're hoping based on no evidence
you're just hoping that this person will
change into becoming well she she
learned about it for the first time when
she went through his phone because he
was in the hospital but he's been
cheating multiple times bro having a
dating app and having Pia done multiple
things for sure and then the first thing
he does when he comes back to being like
my dick works I'm downloading Twitter uh
Twitter gold you know that's what he
does and also too like if you're a guy
like cheating and you got two kids how
do you have a Tinder profile out and
like manage that with two kids like
that's wild because he's not involved
with the children yeah apparently he
also like was constantly uh was
constantly away for work and stuff like
that in like different places so like
let's say uh he was like traveling
domestically for working in all those
places he would like meet up with people
oh wow
I was like imaginary cheat yeah like I
like to like pretend how I would live my
life right because I leave Vegas I come
to Ellie all the time and I'm like oh if
I were to cheat then I'd probably be
convenient to cheat after JK or
something yeah yeah after JK I'm like
man [__] tired
Hey Joe you wanna get some fun yeah
these guys have [__] bounce cheat is
so hard
[Music]
foreign